you made a perfect movie you did A
Perfect movie that everyone loved and it
made over a billion dollars
what would it mean to win tonight it'd
be fantastic you know it's enough to go
battle but still we're thrilled to be
we've already won that we're standing
here we're nominated I'm now an academy
a nominated producer so that's wonderful
we all
we are making these movies to keep
trying to save the movie industry one
film at a time he's so committed to what
he does when he's on a movie you can't
get him off track he's going to stay on
that thing
I'm sure he's training for another stunt
while we're here talking to you can you
can you tell us anything about Pirates
after you get some love there right
behind you there's a man who's
responsible for all this
he's responsible
he's the guy that made it all work
this really is it really is it's
brilliant words and he's a great
producer and a director
what can you tell us about Pirates and
will we see Johnny Depp I'm just going
to ask you straight out we're all
working on it we'll see how it comes out
but we're very excited I think we're
going to have a great screen play and
we're getting close it's still a
possibility that he could come back
we'll see I would love it
I would love to have them in the movie
that's all I can tell you
now guys told us if the movie wins
tonight you
know everybody
take everybody worked on the movie get
up there for sure they're all a part of
it thank you
[Music]
foreign